[Music]
the santa lucia mountain range runs from
monterey and down the coast of
california for hundreds of years stories
have been told about entities that keep
watch over the mountains
sometimes seen out of the corner of the
eye and always from a distance stare too
long and they vanish if you're ever
hiking in the wilderness of big sur and
feel like you're being watched
it's because you are
[Music]
nobody knows how long the dark watchers
have been guarding the santa lucias but
stories go back to the spanish settlers
in the early 18th century the san lucia
mountains were the final obstacle before
reaching the pacific ocean this was a
dangerous climb and had to be done
carefully as they slowly made their way
through the mountains the settlers
reported seeing dark figures watching
them and they called him los vijalantes
oscuros
oh you're not gonna jump in with the
translation um it's literally the title
of the episode i know but usually it's
time to take off the training wheel
sport
my back hurts from carrying you
years later american settlers reported
seeing the same thing so whether native
american tribe spanish settler or casual
hiker everyone who travels the area gets
an anxious feeling that they're being
silently observed it happens in the late
afternoon right before dusk in the hills
usually when it's hazy you feel eyes on
you from somewhere you turn around and
see a dark figure about 10 feet tall it
has long thin legs and arms you can't
see its face except for maybe dimly
glowing eyes some have described them as
wearing wide brimmed hats and cloaks and
just as your eyes adjust and your brain
starts to make sense of what you're
seeing the figure vanishes according to
people who have seen the dark watchers
they are unsettling but don't seem to be
dangerous they spend most of their time
in the shadows of the forest but they
will come out if people are close
legends says they're entities that
follow travelers through the mountains
they have excellent hearing and eyesight
if they detect any type of technology
like a phone or gps they won't appear
one famous person who saw the dark
watchers was the author john steinbeck
in his story flight a character sees a
dark figure staring at him from on top
of the hill abbay looked suspiciously
back every minute or so
and his eyes saw the tops of the ridges
ahead
once on a white bearing spur you saw a
black figure for a moment
but he looked quickly away for it was
one of the dark watchers
no one knew who the watchers were
nor where they lived but it was better
to ignore them and never to show
interest in them
they did not bother one who stayed on
the trail and minded his own business
the dark watchers were a bit of a family
obsession for the steinbeck's john
steinbeck's son thomas wrote a book
about them his mother olive actually
interacted with them she often told
stories about her time as a young
teacher
to get to work she would have to travel
the dark woods of the mountains she said
she saw dark watchers several times and
she would leave gifts of flowers and
food
and would receive gifts from the
watchers on her way home what gift would
she get they wouldn't kill her in her
sleep no the dark watchers would bring
her flowers too creepiest romance ever
there have been sightings of dark
watchers recently and what's spooky is
the descriptions are all very similar
i'll link you to a page where you can
read a bunch of them but here are a few
of my favorites
one day i was hiking the mountains where
i lived near bled california as i went
further on the trail i felt like i was
being watched the hair on my arms stood
up
i turned around worried it was a
mountain lion at the top of the mountain
i saw a hooded human figure i couldn't
see its face
the hood and cloak looked tattered and
ripped it made no sound i turned around
and went back the way i came
i never went back to that area of the
mountain range again
dan phoenix arizona
one day a friend and i were coming back
from los angeles we passed the san luis
obispo reservoir and saw something at
the end of the mountain it was a really
big human figure but it wasn't
it had a black cape like the grim reaper
and holding a staff it was in the
daytime so i knew it wasn't a person
these dark watchers are real
elizabeth san mateo california
so what are the dark watchers well
nobody knows for sure but there are a
couple of theories the first one is that
it's a simple case of pareidolia
pareidolia is the human tendency to
perceive a specific image in a random
visual pattern some cases of pareidolia
can be pretty compelling i mean look at
this well now that will haunt me in my
dreams or the bacon murder clown
yeah you got any funny ones these are
awful a pigeon poops a self-portrait
that's more like it the woman who looks
like a muppet
or these peppers which are apparently
dying to get out
once your brain makes the connection
between that random image and a real
life object you can't not see it the
dark watchers could be long shadows
caused by trees that because of
pareidolia people perceive as tall
figures maybe this is the reason they're
only seen at dawn or dusk this is when
shadows are the longest what people
perceive as a grim reaper's staff is
just a branch and the hats are just the
tops of trees but that doesn't explain
the pictures of the dark watchers
[Music]
there's a phenomenon called the brock
inspector it's named after the broken
peak in the hearts mountains of germany
and for hundreds of years locals have
reported seeing shadowy figures on the
broken peak but what this actually is is
the shadow of a hiker or a mountain
climber what happens is when the sun is
directly behind the subject a shadow is
cast on the mountain mist below the
specters are often surrounded by a
rainbow halo this rainbow effect is
called a glory and is caused by sunlight
refracting off water droplets in the
mist and you can sometimes see this
effect when you fly
if the conditions are right you'll see
the shadow of the plane surrounded by a
glory on the mountain when the sun is
low in the sky like dawn or dusk the
shadow can look huge so could this be
the dark watchers that people are seeing
in the mountains their own shadows nope
i don't know the glories are pretty
spectacular you'd think that would have
worked its way into the story and a
brock inspector will stay there until
the conditions change but everyone who's
claimed to see a dark watcher says they
disappear very quickly and skeptics have
added other theories like hypoxia
vikings at elevation where there's less
oxygen could be causing hallucinations
they also try to explain that feeling of
being watched as a result of being
exposed to infrasound when wind rushes
down the side of a mountain it can
sometimes create sound under 19 hertz
just below human hearing when exposed to
infrasound especially at high amplitudes
many report feeling anxious even fearful
others have reported chills running down
their spine but these theories don't
explain how people see dark watchers
from a moving car i'm not saying they're
real but i will admit the scientific
explanations are a little thin i don't
think we can put this one in the
debunked column will be still my hun
and look people who are new to the
channel sometimes think that i'm a
skeptic set out to debunk their favorite
urban legend but that's absolutely not
what i'm here to do i love the legends
as much as anyone but most of all i want
to know the truth because if we can
debunk 99 of these stories
doesn't that make the other 1
so much more fun
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the white files if you had
fun or learned anything do me a favor
and like subscribe comment and share
that stuff really helps the channel and
thanks to our patrons for making this
channel possible if you'd like to
support the y files consider becoming a
member on patreon or picking up some
white files merchandise there are links
in the description we got hecklefish
t-shirts hecklefish mugs hecklefish baby
clothes hecklefish mousepads okay okay
okay okay they get it
hoodies and that's gonna do it until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you are appreciated
[Music]
you